the mathematician IJ good back in the
mid-1960s introduced what he called the
intelligence explosion which in essence
was the same as the concept that Vernor
Vinge
later introduced and Ray Kurzweil
adopted and called the technological
singularity what IJ good said was the
first intelligent machine will be the
last invention that humanity needs to
make now in the 1960s the difference
between narrow AI and AGI wasn't that
clear and RJ good wasn't thinking about
a system like alphago that could beat go
but couldn't walk down the street or add
five plus five in the modern vernacular
what we can say is the first human level
AGI the first human level artificial
general intelligence will be the last
invention that humanity needs to make
and the reason for that is once you get
a human level AGI you can teach this
human level AGI math and programming and
AI theory in cognitive science and
neuroscience this human level AGI can
then reprogram itself and it can modify
its own mind and it can make itself into
a yet smarter machine it can make 10,000
copies of itself some of which are much
more intelligent than the original and
once the first human level AGI has
created the second one which is smarter
than itself
well that second one will be even better
at AI programming and hardware design
and cognitive science and so forth and
we'll be able to create the third human
level AGI which by now will be well
beyond human level so it seems that it's
going to be a laborious path to get to
the first human level AGI I don't think
it will take centuries from now but it
may be decades rather than years on the
other hand once you get to a human level
AGI I think you may see what some
futures have called the hard takeoff
where you see the intelligence increase
literally day by day as the AI system
rewrites its own mind and this it's a
bit frightening but it's also incredibly
exciting does that mean humans will not
ever make any more inventions of course
it doesn't but what it means is if we do
things right we won't need to if things
come out the way that I hope they will
what will happen is we'll have these
superhuman minds and largely they'll be
doing their own things they will also
offer to us the possibility to upload or
upgrade ourselves and join them in
realms of experience that we cannot now
conceive no current human forms or these
superhuman Agis may help humans to
maintain that traditional human-like
existence I mean if if you have a
million times human IQ and you can
reconfigure elementary particles into
new forms of matter and will then
supplying a few billion humans with you
know food and water and video games
virtual reality headsets and national
parks and flying cars and whatnot this
would be trivial for these super human
minds so if if they are well disposed
toward us
people who chose to remain in human form
could have a simply much better quality
of life than we have now you don't have
to work for a living you can devote your
time to social emotional spiritual
intellectual and creative pursuits
rather than laborious ly doing things
you might rather not do just in order to
get food and shelter and an internet
connection so I think that there is
tremendous positive possibilities here
and there's also a lot a lot of
uncertainty and there's a lot of work to
get to the point where intelligence
explodes in the sense of a hard takeoff
but I do think it's reasonably from
but we can get there in my lifetime
which is which is rather exciting
[Music]